[Music]
YouTube what's up so so grateful that
you clicked and you're about to watch a
new youtube video but before you do -
one two nine three one five seven three
one that is my texting community
platform doing a lot of one-on-one
engagement in there and also access
opportunity first looks in that
environment - one two nine thirty one
five seven three one join it now and now
to the video you've been wanting to
watch if you ask me give me a top ten
great idea to start a business right now
one of them is to start out you got your
prospective
[Applause]
everybody welcome to a conversation on
the podcast a format that it seems that
a lot of people are liking and so we're
gonna continue to do it I'm super
excited about this interview because
this is a great story about if you don't
ask you don't get so I'm gonna let this
lovely lady introduce herself and tell
you who she is then I'll tell you how
she got here and then we're gonna shoot
the [ __ ] what's up what's up see you
back here it's crazy
so I'm Heather Monahan I was formerly a
chief revenue officer in corporate
America for 14 years I got fired two
years ago and when that happened I wrote
and self published my first book
confidence creator which Trump Trump for
number one in business biographies on
Amazon have a screenshot to prove that
one and I've just went out now speaking
I just did my first TED talk Saturday
thank you
and I'm just tearing it up so so I was
on your podcast thank you for that much
you're welcome for that a couple months
ago Heather and then uh thank you and
then at the end or in it or towards the
end you're like can I be on yours and I
said yep you can and the reason one we
had a great I thought it was a great
session on your podcast everyone loved
it yeah actually let's jump into that
how was the feedback amazing and what
was the thing that stood out people said
it was a different version of you
because we talked a lot about family my
grandmother like we really got into some
different topics I think that typically
people don't explore with you which was
cool cool and so great energy to your
point I did think it was it got into a
lot of territories that were different
and yeah I just you know it's funny I
and for everybody listening you've seen
Zane
who's sitting here asks me at a Q&A can
I get a job I say yes he literally works
here you've seen other things you know I
say yes to and then and then I say no
all the time like thousands and
thousands not thousands hundreds and
hundreds of people have asked me in
those kind of scenarios can I be on the
podcast or this or that you can't get a
shout on your social and things of that
nature and I always feel super
comfortable saying no or yes
but to the point and and something that
I'd like to start talking about as a
kickoff point before we go into a little
more context on you and then anything
else you want to talk about is how much
how often do you ask for what you're
looking for how has that worked for you
in your career
when did you develop it hasn't always
been there I think you know I put out a
piece of content recently where I told
everybody to DM every to text everybody
in their address book if they knew
anybody that could give them business
right so if you're selling you know I'm
probably listening if you missed it if
you sell t-shirts if you have an agency
if you have you know a product a book
instead of texting everybody in your
phone and I'm talking like starting with
Aaron Anderson and ending with Zach czar
Linton you know if you text everybody
instead of saying hey can you buy my
book you could say hey I have a new book
Aaron do you know anybody who'd be
interested in it which of course alludes
to maybe them or maybe they actually do
recommend somebody on it that really
struck a chord and I've gotten hundreds
of emails in the last three weeks
of people that did it and had miraculous
results like literally my landscaping
business was about to go under
I was going to like put everything on a
credit card but I saw that clip texted
four hundred eighty three people and
have thirteen new clients and don't need
to take out credit cards like so so much
of why we're sitting here is you just
had the audacity the strategy the balls
the thoughtfulness whatever one wants to
put in front of it
to actually ask which is something
people are super fearful of how are you
with that obviously you did it with me
has that always been there has it not
been there
tell me about you with the relationship
of asking that's my opening question
this is funny so you know Zach that runs
your speaker business yes I do okay so
I'm your speakers doc um so I was on a
conference call with Zach and I don't
know Zach yep and I was gonna be
interviewing Jesse it's learned Sarah
bleakly a month ago in Boston and so
they had this call with me to like
basically strategize how it would go and
whatnot so I said listen Zach I don't
know you but here's the thing I want to
come out to biggie small more money more
problem me and Jesse will go like
rip this thing up and start wrapping
he's like excuse me uh no this is we do
it traditional and burn but if you don't
like think out of the box and then just
bring it like whatever crazy heat you
have you're gonna get nothing I want it
to be memorable like I want people to
say holy cow like so did I get what I
want
no he didn't do it which is fine but he
will remember me forever because as soon
as he saw me at hyper-growth he's like
oh my god you're that crazy lady that
wants to come out with Jesse rapping yes
you know so like even if you don't get
what you're going for you're gonna be
remembered forever are you better at
asking for things in business or in
personal life or biomass yeah me too me
neither
I'm I have so much less fear of knowing
business than I did growing up with like
girls I like so much more I still like
laughs like thinking like why am i 13
and willing to like do actual business
with 43 year olds but I'm like scared to
ask like Stacey Johnson to the dance I
said I'm the same same and I'm and by
the way what's ironic about that is I
actually have seen far more people the
other way I always used to think it was
one in the same and like it was really
funny to me to see like guys or gals
that were good social life wise asking
crippled by cold calling or cold
emailing or asking which is why I asked
you that I've come to realize Wow for
some reason there's some sort of
difference in those two worlds and I'm
curious about who thinks that both who's
great at both and then who's good at one
or the other and which one I wish I was
good in my personal life now what was
your what was the most business seat
thing you did when you grew up was being
a kid yeah were you in business oh yeah
I mean I had a paper I was I grew up
poor my mom was a regular Worcester Mass
no Bible wait remember that's what
druggie and I had remember yeah so no I
had a paper route since I was nine I
worked at fast-food restaurants I was
you know a busboy at like diners you
know I just always worked and so what
about entrepreneurship versus job
obviously were CRO now you've got fired
you're doing your own thing yeah it's
crazy was because you know a lot of
people that grow up with that versity
single mom having to work
love the stability of a real serious job
yes you went that I love that I never
thought about being an entrepreneur that
was crazy yeah can you tell the kids
that are listening that you know neither
one of us are under 25 so I know right
so so like how much weeding grow up with
entrepreneurship even being an option no
you're the poster boy for the
entrepreneurial world but that didn't
exist when we were kids everyone was in
corporate America I didn't even know
there was such a thing like that wasn't
that wasn't something somebody talked
about yeah like the only way you heard
it is like oh they own their own
business you would not use the word
entrepreneur now and as a matter of fact
the word entrepreneur the few times I
did hear it usually meant rich kid who
does nothing and parents it's really
interesting like that's how I recall it
like four or five guys that I can think
of growing up as 16 22 21 like they
would have like a card that was like I'm
an entrepreneur and I was like what does
that mean and basically then somebody
else when they would leave be like oh
they just live on the beach PhD PhD Papa
has dealership yes yeah that was I mean
that was the entrepreneur back in the
day what are you most thinking about
these days like what do you what is your
business today well right now my number
one revenue stream is a speaking
business which is insane I can't believe
how much money I get paid it's crazy
it's so exciting I wish I had known
about this how many times did you speak
for free if ever I just felt for free
the freaking thing I'm talking about
prior to getting paid or was your first
career for 20 years in corporate America
I was like a Sales Leader every day I
spoke you're speaking to your team but
how about after you got fired actually
tell that quick story before we run out
of time
the framework of what I recall from our
podcast and really where you go you had
this big gig you got fired yeah to make
an adjustment yeah I know that was a
scariest thing because I wasn't I wasn't
comfortable with that unknown space like
how you are you've you know you've
always been in this year that's my world
for me that was never my world I like
that safe I use I was tricking myself I
thought it was really safe being in
corporate America which is [ __ ]
because any company can be sold tomorrow
and you only have your brand in you and
your experiences in your network so you
are not safe unless you are actually
doing it I feel
so much safer now that I've worked for
myself in control I'm in control I trust
my boss you know like I I'm not gonna
sell the company I'm good you know and
just it's such a it's a seismic shift to
think about how I what's the first thing
you thought so you get have you fired in
person yeah in a two minute meeting so
that no with the new CEO the CEO I had
worked for for 14 years became ill he
elevated his daughter to replace him and
she immediately said come over I need to
have a meeting with you and she
basically passed two memos in front of
me and said I don't need a chief revenue
officer anymore I don't need you which
memo would you like to sign and once
that Heather Monaghan's been fired and
the other one said you know Heather
Monaghan wonderful employee blah blah
blah but I knew this wasn't my first
rodeo I knew then there's did you have
any relationship with her well she was
the CFO and I was a CRO s-- and we were
like she wanted to cut everything and I
want to spend everything I got and of
course let me know it's but I never know
what she called you over it was kaput
skis or did you call she's a smart woman
yes she's very analytical and she's a
CFO she was right she's the antithesis
of me but I got she knew like I think
you need a job I'm not gonna fire her I
figured she was gonna rough me up a
little you know to or trying to get
aligned yeah well I didn't think so were
you shocked I was crying I mean I cried
the whole rat three hour ride home did
you did you do you have it in you in
that scenario like what's funny about me
is every time anything happens I start
the process of worst-case scenario
Dustin emails me and says I need three
minutes with you the first this is real
it's just I just it just happened the
first thing I think is I hope he's not
sick like I go so funny I go into like
what's the worst that can happen I hope
he's not sick I hope something terribly
something weird didn't happen like you
know like John did something weird to
him and it needs to go to HR that's the
next to me it's in this order something
that's that person or their family is
sick next something like super
politically incorrect legal sexual
harassment that's the next worst thing
third is a good employees wants to leave
so if like a good employee says I need
to see you that's the third thing I
think but like that's all I think I
don't think like oh it's gonna be a five
minute check
and this is by the way everyone who's
listening this is the [ __ ] a bone in
your [ __ ] like this is actually the way
you think this is why it's interesting
what you like it's crazy to me
but it makes so much sense which is why
I'm jumping on this point I'd never
really thought about this the only thing
I would have thought when she wanted to
see me is I'm getting fired but when I
just realized based on your reaction
literally just hit me is like right when
you're completely accountable to
yourself which is what you're figuring
out now all the greatness of loving your
boss and feeling safe the [ __ ] part is
the way my brain actually works listen
to what I'm telling you every time
anyone reaches out to me in order I
think about terminal illness for them or
their want loved one sexual harassment
or stealing or something horrible third
is they're leaving and we value them
that is literally the order that my head
goes then it's like hey Gary can we get
500 bucks for a TGIF Friday's party next
Thursday for the team I'm like yes I
always oh that's why I'm always in a
good mood when it's anything but three
and the third ones not even that scary
because genuinely on the record for
anybody from Vayner that hears this if
one feels like they're ready to move on
I want to help them it's the first two
that scared the [ __ ] out of me and
always what I think every time a client
reaches out we're getting fired never
we're getting more growth of business
macro I'm optimistic macro I'm like
we're gonna win we're the best micro
micro I'm not that means something big I
don't know what it isn't let me tell you
what it's got let me tell you let me
tell you what it means in your world
when you're walking in their micro she's
about to [ __ ] fire me macro I'm
[ __ ] a capable human being I'm gonna
[ __ ] figure it out whether I'm gonna
get another [ __ ] job that's gonna pay
me more or I'm gonna start my own career
in [ __ ] speak at TEDx got it yeah I
was but I was the opposite of that I
understand that's which is what I'm
thinking of why I'm saying this so
aggressively is cuz there's two people
listening right now in this show in the
framework of business entrepreneurs and
employees and it's like an interesting
debate for people that are like for
example there's a lot of people that are
employees right now that are thinking
about making the jump where they listen
to what I just said and are saying do I
want to live a life where I have to
always be that on and
at all times coz yes I'm a firefighter
like what's amazing about your life
right now is you're in control what's
terrible is you're in control right like
if you decide to chill this morning like
if Dustin isn't I'm just looking at him
if dozens just like not feeling it today
and I'm like pumped all the time and
have days when you wake up and he's not
fully feeling it one could argue that
you can call out sick you can lollygag
your day you can for me that's that like
I'm like oh the reason I haven't had a
sick day in nine years is that's more
scary than the lollygag obviously if I
run 105 fever I'm willing to stay home
but all those days I mean I call that a
school 13 to 23 times a year I made
pretend I was sick 13 times a year once
I figured out in high school that the
nurse had to send you home if you
weren't willing to go back to class
legally it was over I just laid there
until they sent me home I'm like I'm
nauseous I'm unconscious I feel weird
I'm anxious to get me out of here and
then the best part was I'd go outside my
mom would have to pick me up freshmen
sophomore year and junior year before I
got my car and literally I would never
look at her because I second I would
look at her eyes I would just start
laughing because we both knew the gig
anyway not to not to tell you what
happens you cry all the way home and
then what I went under a weighted
blanket grabbed a bottle of Chardonnay
and then I did somehow I was short of
empathy but how was it it was good okay
all right so here's the thing though I
did something super smart and I had
never done it I posted on social media
that I just got fired I just was
vulnerable and I just said I need your
amended something I needed help I didn't
know what to do and it was crazy
froggie from the Elvis Duran show
tweeted at me I want to help use their
anyway can help you and I wrote and I
treated back yeah get me booked me on
Elvis he booked me right away to go on
the Elvis show I went on the show and
halfway through the interview Elvis says
well obviously you're writing a book and
I said well obviously but I wasn't so I
googled on the plane on the way home how
do you read a book and it says just
right so I was like I can do that so I
just went home and I just started
writing and writing and then you know it
took like two months and I was done with
my budget did you debate self-publishing
because I heard you earlier say that
versus getting a book deal was the book
deal too long and drawn doubt and you
wanted to get it out speed to market so
you know obviously with my
history and business I knew speed to
market it's critical and I've got to
move fast and I'm gonna move so much
faster than some traditional publishing
house so I'm glad an example did you
consider getting a job like going back
to a job yes so I had to sign I had to
sign a non-compete when I took the chief
revenue officer position so for one year
I couldn't go back to media yeah so I
thought to myself if I'm gonna start
over as a rookie somewhere
why wouldn't I roll the dice on me
versus you know I'm gonna go do
something new whatever you write the
book so I write the book and then I
Google how do you promote a book and you
speak to promote a book so I was like oh
that's easy I already know how to speak
I didn't know there was a speaking
business I had no idea I mean either
before I got into it it's so crazy to me
I always think how many other things do
we not know about that we could be very
comfortable amount so that's what's so
exciting I mean that's my entire thesis
when there was some gal in line in this
speech I gave and she's like Gary I know
your thesis of tastings in your 20s and
figure out what you love or what you're
great at or what there's much what did
your point and she's like but I've done
all that like what do I do and I looked
at her she was from Belarus too so I was
like you know kind of like from the
homeland I'm like let me get this
straight you've decided that you've done
everything on earth and you now know
everything it was just it was funny to
watch her like realize oh I've only done
nine things and there's nine billion
things there's so many things well it's
like I was just mentioning to you Marcia
Kilgore how she's disrupted the beauty
business look at that this is someone
who has been in the beauty business for
a couple of decades and one day just
said hey I'm gonna flip this whole model
upside down now it just challenges me to
think how can I flip everything upside
down
everything is in play cuz the internet
bookstores and limos are just the first
ones everything every single thing is
vulnerable everything everything what do
you want it everybody who's listening
like you like eyelash extensions
vulnerable you like ice cream vulnerable
you like kindergarten vulnerable
literally this is why I like people you
know sometimes struggle to understand
what I'm saying all of it the answer is
yes there's nothing that is protected
Amazon is vulnerable I'm telling you
right now let me explain what I mean by
that if you ask me give me a top
ten great idea to start a business right
now one of them is to start a local book
store that's shocking I that's why I'm
making a point of it I believe that we
are at enough scale of books being
delivered by Amazon that the countermove
is now up for debate that if you build a
trendy coffee we were key co-working
kind of vibey Drybar Sephora rad [ __ ]
book store that people will go that if
you make it experiential and have
another variable that people pay the
extra dollars that are more than Amazon
to be there I don't know I I had so I
had the TED talk I ordered like seven
dresses online cuz when you're a woman
you have to really think about what
you're gonna wear first what about
madness no it's not as big a deal for a
man it's not you're not gonna be
scrutinized the way that I would be I
think it's time that we started having
counter debates of where we have some
men are like wildly focused on what
they're wearing they're not gonna be
scrutinized oh well enough yeah I mean
everyone's gonna talk about what I wore
like it's too sexy or it's not she's not
why but why does that matter
I don't know it matters in a woman's
head they just it these are the things
women think about men think about how
much money they make how tall they are
men think about a lot of things - what
I'm not making a men women thing I'm
making it a how do you eliminate that
because then you go fast now move out of
Miami that's what I should do to
eliminate that or just not value
people's opinions pro or con here right
you all right I want that for you
because I want everybody I wanna bring I
want yeah forever I went to the Knicks
game last night
and had 400,000 it was my friend said to
me
holy [ __ ] you're more popular than every
Nick and when I tell you that I can't
even feel it
I can't which is why I can handle the
next morning when somebody wrote a blog
post to say that I'm trying to exploit
this sports car to industry cuz tops pay
me $25,000 to curate a set like you know
you need to be able to I really want
this for you and I have a lot of empathy
when you talk about women's appearance
like like the enormity of dm's that I
get from women that say look easy for
you like I spent 40 years
before I go on film and I'm like look
there's so many like I understand that
historical truths you know men and women
are different there's a million things
that go into that
but there are so many men that are shy
to go on camera because of their looks
and there are so many women that are not
and vice versa sorry and and and I'm
just trying to get everybody into a
mindset of happiness which is actually
truth of elimination of judgment but
nonetheless you might also enjoy it like
it just might be fun for you
subconsciously to go through seven
dresses no maybe not absolutely pure
hell understood tell me okay so the
whole point is that so I had to order
all these dresses because I want to get
the right outfit and Drive myself crazy
but then I got in these dresses from
Saks and I look at I usually order from
revolve which is a customer center in a
business right so it's easy to do
business than return stuff also great
pricing right free pricing great
products this is hashtag not an n-well
Ollis and I look at Saks you would have
to pay if you want to return it via UPS
or whatever so I'm like I'm not gonna do
that I'll bring it into the store
because you know that's just principle
it's wrong so I bring it into the store
I hadn't been in the store a long time
the guy literally is like listen here's
my card the guy that works at the desk
there's no one in the store and he said
here's my card next time you order
online if you can just include this code
now I'll get a commission and I thought
to myself this model is so freakin
broken that this poor sales guy is like
begging for someone to you know use
their code so that they can make a
dollar off of something that these tough
people come in the store and you know
what that model is just broken yeah I
mean that suck that whole experience
that you just like or I would never go
to Saks again if somebody asked me that
horrible experience I'm not I'm not mad
at Saks I'm just mad at the whole thing
I feel bad for the guy well obviously
it's not I mean they're not training
their people and there's so many issues
there the customer is not the focus is
it's all broken yeah before we head out
because we don't have that much time
what is what's on your mind what do you
want to share with the audience what do
you talk about these oh my gosh stepping
into fear because I was paralyzed by
fear for so long I knew that lady didn't
like me when I was working there but I
would just ignore it all the time
chipped away at me my Commodore should
weigh it like my potential and when you
rolled yourself in a situation at some
point you have to look in the mirror and
say like enough is enough
yeah I've got to like just go out there
and take a chance on me and I I wasn't
able to do that I got pushed out but I'm
so glad now that I did and this TED talk
that I did it's so ridiculous standing
on a little red circle and having a
ticker going off for ten minutes it was
the one most stressful things I've done
but once you're done with it it's like I
said to myself right when I was walking
out there maybe I'm gonna bomb right now
I don't know cuz this is not like any
I've ever done but I'm gonna love me so
much more like when I get off the stage
when I walked out there sure and so what
since the fear professionally have you
stepped in - oh my gosh everything left
my fiancee that I've been in a
relationship with for eight years or so
that was like massive yeah it's like a
domino effect for sure of you know
different things that have occurred and
I keep like pushing myself to try
different things and like go to that
talk to me about your so speaking as a
core thing for you yeah that's my number
one thing so let's talk about personal
brand building which would lead to more
speaking gigs yeah what are you doing
content wise how are you thinking about
that I'm not doing a good job of that
I need a d-roc in my life I mean that's
definitely the next investment hey
Ronnie heart is not the punchline it's
it's the strategy that makes you
comfortable with it but you could have a
d-roc you could have had a strategy but
if you don't have the team to execute it
and cut up a team well it's where do you
want to make your investment I mean
that's what you had a respect you you
need so you're saying it's a financial
that's a different dimensional question
do you believe if you tweeted much like
you tweeted I got fired yeah that I'm
looking for an intern for a very low
cost but I'll but you'll get the skill
set to do the d-roc thing and can you
afford it whether you're a super hungry
and you think it's strategically right
because you get close to me or be you
just come from highly wealthy parents
who are gonna subsidize your life during
this time and you want the experience do
you feel like you get that person you're
right that's a good point
okay let's so that's that let's put that
on the shelf what app what else are you
doing on content where are you on
LinkedIn oh I kill unlink tell me well
how often you post what
you post how are you thinking about it
you know what I don't strategize tell me
the truth because I want really want to
help you and he's like final minutes how
often do you post on LinkedIn all the
day once a day
yeah written well I do videos but then
my viral pose like I've had millions of
views on my post it's always 9
professional pictures of like that's the
recipe for whatever reason and sharing
something vulnerable those ones go viral
for me have you have you tried to use
LinkedIn like Twitter I've been thinking
about this a lot I've been thinking
about the notion of LinkedIn's
algorithm is highly organic right now
and one or two sentences of thoughtful
business chatter three or four sentences
on the fly like you're going down the
elevator now after this podcast and we
talked about something that you thought
about and be like literally here's
literally the LinkedIn post just did a
podcast made me really think about you
know what the things I continue to say
no to that are actually yeses I just
need to look at them from a different
angle it's what I always challenge
myself for because I think what I'm good
at and giving advice for that is a
LinkedIn post would take you 39 seconds
I think you should be posting based on
what you're trying to achieve in your
career eight to 15 times a day and
LinkedIn get out of here and that's not
gonna be overkill you don't think no
bamming people know because people
aren't gonna see it all right but people
who understand is the algorithm the
thing that people haven't figured out is
the algorithm is on the side of the
person that's consuming it not on the
side of the person that's making it
interesting and so the algorithm is
gonna you know who it's gonna overkill
the forty nine people on earth that
think you're the greatest thing of all
time and I'm gonna see all fifty-nine
with it that's gonna be pumped right I'd
like to get forty nine piece of content
from Randy in the Macho Man Savage in
nineteen eighty eight every day of my
life
you know so no that's why the algorithms
work people blame the algorithms like
[ __ ] you I'm like the algorithm is there
for the people it's consumer-centric the
reason algorithms work is because after
consumer-centric if you think i'm rad
you're gonna see me cuz you're gonna
slow down when you're consuming it
you're gonna consume you're gonna like
you're gonna comment and that's an
indicator that you're gonna see it do
you respond to haters when they post no
you do not always right now the sheer
volume
between text messages social email that
I'm getting is unsustainable even if I
did it for 18 hours a day but I'm very I
am thirty minute uh 30 minute coffee
this morning with a gentleman who I
wouldn't call my hater but was
aggressively pushing back against me on
social and we had a lovely conversation
about like marketing and how we see it
differently I get a lot of value I mean
look there's people that are making up
stuff the kid that wrote the article
today about me in the sports card world
made up stuff cuz I posted a photo of a
box of cards yesterday which I did for
my friend that runs stock acts Josh as a
friendly gesture he's turned it into
this highly like hidden compensate I
mean people are delusional
so that I don't get a lot of value out
of lying or mean hey if somebody you
know haters that pick on women and use
sexual you're not gonna there's no
engagement they're people that are like
Gary you're a charlatan like like you're
full of [ __ ] you like what have you ever
done I'm comfortable jumping in be like
hey I understand you may not like the
Instagram videos or I might come across
too aggressive but like on that point of
what have I ever done I do think there
should be a discussion of like I've
built two massive businesses like and to
that point that might be a framework to
a conversation if their reply to use
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] then I'm like okay
this needs to move on if they're like
okay that makes sense I didn't realize
that then I then I'll come back and be
like hey what about you like what do you
do like I'm I'm very capable of dealing
with negativity because I come I come at
it from compassion and empathy they
don't know me right everybody in this
room doesn't know me and I know these
these tree hang out with me a lot and
have a lot of access to me they don't
fully know me who knows you so when
people are casting judgment like this is
why I don't take compliments hi either
that's hard that is really but you have
to train yourself to do that well this
is why you know I look at I look at like
there's a couple things that people
really struggle with if you're
attractive as a guy or gal inevitably
you're in trouble because you grew up in
a life where people told you were
attractive and you took that in if you
had high success in school if you had
high success in sport you know by not
being an attractive scholar or
I had none of those over things and so
what actually gave me reinforcement was
the end market nobody complimented me
except the results of my little
businesses so I became market driven not
people's opinions driven my friends got
it that's what I've self analyzed so
that's what I'm looking for everybody
else to do
forget about individual opinions what's
the score say do people like I always
tell people do the people that know you
best like you see my thing is there's so
many people out there that are admired
but if you look carefully their inner
circles garbage that's sad well that's a
lot of people that people think are
awesome like a lot of people that get
exposed later in the news like bad
shipme to fraud to go to jail if you
look carefully you can be like why don't
they happen inner circle why aren't
there people there for a long time
that's like I'm like why do I have
people around me forever like like it's
not super complicated like people get
confused and then the reverse so to me
I'd rather the people that know me the
best admire me the most and the people
that don't know me at all and are
insecure and upset with themselves hate
me the most absolutely that's the game
done viewers are real you need to
challenge yourself in my opinion to play
that exact frit
you are not naturally that person just
like I'm not naturally work out well
like it's really fun to think I don't do
radical candor well cuz I hate micro
negativity which has led to all my
vulnerabilities that's what I'm working
on you need to [ __ ] go all-in on
everything that is judgment I love that
that's the game for you all right I'm in
final point you haven't what you get the
floor for last 30 to 60 seconds fear is
a liar and confidence is the one thing
that can change everything for anyone
and it's a choice it's not something
you're born with it is a practice right
it's a discipline and it's a decision
every day when you wake up but it's the
game changer I'm gonna add and I
apologize I said you get the last word
but I'm [ __ ] I'm completely flawed it
just made me think of something judge
the judge ER a couple of new big
executives have come to Boehner and like
wow this place is [ __ ] amazing
and I'm like why and both
the same thing they said after six
months they're like you don't just
blindly take content and context from
people you actually 360 it and I'm like
what do you mean they're like well a
couple weeks ago I told you
Sally Magoo sucked and you came back a
week later and said you have a wrong
perspective because you only took it
from one person's point of view
and you were right after I did the
homework judge the judge or my friends
if somebody says you're ugly you have to
decide who that person is including your
mom
including your dad abs most importantly
those people because those people are
coming from their their own Challenger
they're so right people get feedback and
I'm stupid I'm like because Ricky Magoo
said your stupid judge the judge er
that's the easiest way to get into a
fear-based here's my framework I don't
let anybody else's opinion override my
own judge the judger and when I lose
because there is no judge or it's just
the market my book didn't sell my sports
car didn't sell my business did bad we
got fired I accept it I own it when the
market says you lost you have to own it
it's like sports either you lost or
you're one and when you lose you have to
accept it and but anything that's a
subjective judgment judge the judge er
that's how you get a relationship with
fear so good awesome thanks for being on
thank you
you